people of the internet sony just dropped
a new playstation trailer that does
indeed feature hogwarts legacy but what
does it all mean and did they actually
reveal a tiny tiny snippet of the game
that we haven't seen before we'll cover
it all in today's video retro reckons
who are here and in this new trailer
from playstation we see quite a few
games very rapidly i might add flash
across the screen the entire trailer
only lasts about 50 seconds long they
actually tweeted it out around 11 am
back on friday august 27th it's okay if
you haven't seen it yet i'll make sure
to link it down in the description below
the trailer is basically just a sizzle
reel of games for ps4 and ps5 and as
these games are playing it features
words like belonging and courage and
freedom flashing across the screen most
of the titles here are first party
titles but not all of them and one of
those third party titles is indeed
hogwarts legacy it actually appears
about five or six times in the trailer
although each time it does it's just for
a few seconds now if you're new here and
you're looking for more than just a few
seconds on the game be sure to check out
all of my other hogwarts legacy videos
here we have a ton of stuff talking
about theories on the game and of course
all the news that we've gotten to this
point but in terms of this specific
trailer there are actually three key
points that i think hogwarts legacy fans
should take away from this number one i
think this just about confirms that sony
does have some sort of marketing
exclusivity deal with the game if you
remember back at the initial unveiling
of the game the very first time we saw
it at least in an official capacity was
at the ps5 showcase event all the way
back in september of 2020. i know feels
like it was so much longer than a year
ago in addition to that trailer they
also had a playstation blog post that
went up shortly after talking even more
about the game then 2021 rolls around
and all we've gotten this year is the
delay announcement eh not so fun and
then the second thing we've gotten was
when the warner media ceo jason keller
tweeted out a couple of concept art
images i know guys there's actually been
very little to discuss now in this time
frame it just so happens that
playstation has also been very quiet as
well despite being the market leader
right now at least in terms of next gen
market leader very very quiet so when
you take that combined with the blog
post and the initial reveal and the fact
that hogwarts legacy and wb have been so
quiet i do think this just about
confirms the fact that they do have some
type of agreement where sony has the
marketing exclusivity for this game now
if you're new or maybe you don't follow
gaming news very closely this does not
mean that hogwarts legacy is exclusive
to playstation it's still coming out on
xbox it's still coming out on pc but
what this does mean is that anytime you
see a trailer for hogwarts legacy it's
probably gonna have the playstation logo
at the end or maybe at the beginning you
see this with a lot of those big
third-party titles like call of duty's
kind of went back and forth over the
years between who has the marketing
exclusivity for between microsoft and
sony and so that brings me to the second
key takeaway here and that is that sony
must believe very very strongly in this
game we talked about how it is still
coming to pc it is still coming to xbox
but even knowing that sony wanted to
pony up the funds to pony up the
probably millions of dollars so they get
the exclusive marketing rights and to me
i don't think you do that unless you
really strongly believe in the quality
of this product and really what this
indicates to me is that sony wants
people to associate hogwarts legacy with
the playstation brand and given how
strong both the harry potter and
playstation brands are that is honestly
huge even though it's coming out on
other platforms they want you to think
of playstation 4 and playstation 5 as
the place to play hogwarts legacy and
regardless of how you feel about
marketing deals or exclusivity in
general you can already see how this is
working i remember when the first
announcement came out we saw that first
trailer there were a lot of folks who
thought oh this is exclusive to
playstation not so fast and to me i'm
just gonna say hopefully this is a sign
that the game is actually shaping up
very nicely maybe sony saw something
early in development or even later in
development where they said hey we want
this game to be exclusive at least in
terms of marketing to playstation and to
be completely clear here just because
sony is throwing their massive marketing
dollars behind hogwarts legacy that does
not mean that the game is guaranteed to
be a quality game but if you think about
the business side of it at least in
terms of sony side clearly they believe
very strongly in this game and if you're
a fan of hogwarts legacy to me that's
nothing but a good thing i mean just
think about it the next gen leader right
now wants hogwarts legacy to appear
right next to horizon right next to
ratchet in that trailer and maybe it's
just me but i personally feel a lot
better about my expectations for the
game the third big takeaway i have here
is that i think we will almost certainly
see hogwarts legacy again at sony's next
big event if you've been a follower of
the channel for a while you know i
haven't really talked much about this
supposed playstation event one because
it's not official yet and two because
the rumors just won't seem to quiet down
every time i think about making a video
there's already another new rumor saying
well no now it's going to be this date
and several different insiders have kind
of went back and forth on this when the
exact date of that next big playstation
event is supposed to be
at the time of this recording though we
still do not have an official date what
sony event you might say well if you
haven't noticed playstation has been
very quiet in 2021 they've delayed some
games they've talked about hey ps5 is
selling really great but they skipped
out on e3 they skipped out on gamescom
they're not doing a playstation
experience this year so a lot of folks
in the industry are expecting they're
not going to go all of 2021 without
saying something about the games they've
got coming up for next year but who
knows when this event is actually going
to take place we've heard all sorts of
dates being thrown out there august now
we're into september who knows maybe
october november maybe they do a
december event bring back the
playstation experience right now though
we have no idea now if you want to know
my personal guess i do think there will
be some sort of sony event focusing on
ps5 before the end of the year i think
it would just be a huge surprise if sony
goes all of 2021 really without saying
anything at all about what games are on
the horizon and i gotta say i know we've
been close or we've thought we've been
close many times guys that like maybe
this is where we're getting hogwarts
legacy news maybe it's going to be here
maybe it's at this event maybe it's at
that event i really do think there's a
strong indication that whenever sony
holds this event that will be the next
moment that we hear about hogwarts
legacy at first i was thinking more
along the lines of maybe the game awards
at the end of the year but the fact that
we've seen this show up in another
playstation trailer tells me that hey
they've got the exclusive for this so
they are going to want to feature it at
playstation events so guys once they are
ready to share more i think you can get
excited because sony is going to put
their full marketing effort behind this
game which means we should be seeing a
lot of information coming out trailers
more playstation blog posts screenshots
hopefully all those things we've been
talking about and hoping for dev
interviews hopefully we're going to see
more of that once they finally say hey
we're ready to tell you guys more about
this game now there is one shot in the
trailer some of you have actually hit me
up on twitter asking do i think this
shot right here is this from hogwarts
legacy notice it takes place after a
hogwarts legacy scene that we've already
seen in the trailer many times and then
we see this right here and it certainly
does look like it could be something
from hogwarts legacy we see someone in
what appears to be a cloak here and then
maybe a mirror shattering and i will say
it certainly looks like it could be from
hogwarts legacy but i tend to think it
is actually final fantasy instead all
the other shots in the trailer that we
see of hogwarts legacy are ripped
straight from the other trailer that we
have seen many many times at this point
i think it would be really strange if
they just kind of snuck that in there
just some sort of random shot from
hogwarts legacy and let's be real here
even if it was from hogwarts legacy i
don't know that we could really gain all
that much from it it is a very very
short shot and as i said it just looks
like someone's standing in a cloak and
this mirror or something magical kind of
shattering in front of them but go ahead
and comment below and let me know what
game you guys think it is and as always
thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon